ah action I'm gonna leave this in the
video really okay so I get that it's
Sunday and I was having just a fantastic
day off but then I noticed the cyberpunk
had released a new trailer and as
someone who's quite interested in
cyberpunk I just have to take a look at
sup guys my name is Jonah welcome back
to another one of these kind of game
engine developer react to whatever we
have here today we're gonna be taking a
look at the new cyberpunk trail or
something that I just really want to
watch as soon as possible I think it's
definitely one of the most anticipated
games that's supposed to be coming out
later this year and I say supposed to be
because they've already delayed it once
so who knows what's gonna happen with
the world this year one thing that that
was particularly interesting to me
actually when looking at this was that
obviously it's it's coming to Xbox one
ps4 and PC November 19th this year so
this is not like a next-gen game when I
first saw this trailer pop up in my feed
I thought that oh well like maybe
they've got like some PS 5 gameplay or
something like that but norm this seems
to still be kind of lost Jan I mean I'm
sure the PC the pace a game plays
probably gonna look amazing but anyway
it'll be interesting to like look at
this and compare it essentially to
what's possible with last gen because
we've just finished watching like the
Ratchet and Clank kind of next-gen stuff
so let's take a look at what we've got
I have no idea what device this is
actually running on and there's also a
little bit difficult to see if
anything's pre-rendered or not these
first frames look amazing I love this
like this this setting it really takes
me back to like walking through the
streets of Tokyo at night like it's it's
really cool you'll notice as well that
there really like there's a lot of neon
lights going around and because there's
there's so much lighting that
immediately just already elevates like
the quality or the the the perceived
quality I'll say of the actual frame a
lot of these lights aren't even casting
shadows really they don't need to the
fact that the ambience just is so well
lit and you can see that the air looks
like it's being affected by the light so
that's obviously implying some kind of
dust particles or something like that
none of that actually even has to be
present there inside the game inside the
engine but the fact that they're kind of
using this bloom and using all of these
lights everywhere that that just goes a
long way this rain I mean if I have to
criticize it a little bit I don't really
like the way the rain looks I mean and
just all these cars driving down here as
well this it says in-game footage so I'm
sure this isn't like a pre-rendered
cutscenes or anything like that but in
general the weight of the game is I mean
I don't want to be harsh because I'm
very much looking forward to this game
but it reminds me a little bit of like
GTA 3 and I'm sorry well something like
Vice City just the way that these kind
of roads are with these cars driving of
course as we get closer in it'll
probably look a little bit better but at
the moment just my first initial
thoughts are this kind of looks like
Vice City
come on like those Saints are amazing
let's go back a little bit this scene I
love this scene you know like look
there's so much going on here there's so
much environmental detail that's really
moving I can't wait to explore this
world
sorry for stopping so much they'll be
linked in the description to the
original trail if you guys haven't
watched that watch that first and maybe
come back and watch this cuz I am gonna
like analyze this pretty thoroughly I
love I love how much detail there is in
all of these streets like that to me is
so cool like just you know driving
through and seeing so many signs that
you can look at that you can check out
stuffs coming soon you know I wouldn't
be surprised if they maybe even
integrate some real-world ads into this
but it's just it's circle
nature week rolling here cos Dex is
pulling the strings doubt that puts in
saying we lose them but we are they just
don't know it yet but if you got the
cojones and you know how to use them you
could do damn near anything good do damn
those awesome shiny shiny bodies I guess
they're like completely robots yo mr. V
a pleasure so what's the game this is
cool it's kind of gives me a JD i-55
Biggs how about we go over the plan this
prototype biochip to be precise jobs to
grab guessing it belongs to a court era
soccer
some heavy-hitters of course you guys
know I noticed the reflection look at
that that's something nice it's also
worth noting that it's like you know
this reflection is is off-screen so of
course it's not it's not screen-space
reflections I don't know what this is
running on if it's they didn't say while
this was running on so I don't know if
it's on PC if it's on PC then I expect
there to be like right trace reflections
and all that stuff if it's on a
Playstation 4 or an Xbox one then well
nor but it is right like it's really
hard to tell what they're doing for that
specifically how wrists have a ward
first rule of the afterlife King baby
it goes without saying we do this on the
hush I deal in nobodies not a one sound
simple enough
gamer's could be and you who are you
cost Keanu is here plays great also on
Xbox series X and PS 5 so is that like
some kind of like just backwards
compatibility thing are they actually
making a version that runs on those
consoles I'm not sure I don't know if
that's like Wow
or like what on earth is going on over
here it's very not well filtered going
back a little bit as well this kind of
table here seems to have quite a lot of
reflections going on you can see it's
being it's very hard to tell some of
these things if they're just like
specular highlights but like this
specifically is a reflection so that's
really cool I'm not sure how dynamic it
is if it's dynamic then it's probably
looking like there is some ray tracing
going on it was very difficult to
actually say ok so that's the trailer Oh
what do I say about this the first thing
I want to say is I think that looking at
all of this next gen stuff maybe has
spoiled me a little bit overall I think
it's a great looking game there's
nothing that I can pinpoint as being not
good if I'm being completely honest I
feel like I'm almost a little bit
disappointed this story is very
interesting and the environment like the
setting that this is taking place in is
also really really cool and I mean I
absolutely still can't wait to play this
game but having to look at it as like a
game engine development specifically I
guess looking at all the graphics in
this game I think the best thing that
they've done here is the environment
like the the detail of the environment
is really it's just really dense there's
so much stuff going on as a result of
that I
think and the fact that they are still
having to develop this for the last
generation of consoles PlayStation 4
Xbox one I can feel that the assets that
they're using are kind of lower quality
now keep in mind that I have been
looking at like next-gen stuff and
Unreal Engine 5 and all that stuff so
I've probably already transitioned into
the the next-gen of assets but a lot of
these textures that I saw weren't the
highest resolution there's kind of an
overall softness that I'm kind of
perceiving here in in what I'm seeing
like the textures don't seem like
they're awfully sharp or an awfully high
resolution same goes for the models but
I think the upside to that is the amount
of stuff that's going on in the frame I
think that's very impressive the
environments are very dense there's they
feel quite full it doesn't look like
they've just got like some road and some
buildings but they're really really high
quality models it looks like they've
just got so much actual content so much
stuff going on in each scene in each
frame that maybe because of that they
couldn't really push the individual
assets to be like kind of you know the
center of attention with very high
quality and that by far is the coolest
thing that I'm seeing here is just being
able to explore these environments I
don't know how open world or how kind of
sandbox this game is is if it's gonna be
like The Witcher then great but
ultimately those environments make me
for sure the most excited it's really
interesting to take a look at what is in
the next-gen game because it could it
feels to me completely different and and
that in itself I think is a cool
reminder of just how much better
next-gen is anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button what
did you guys think of this trailer was
it was a even more hype than you were
are you kind of a little bit
disappointment do you see where I'm
coming from what you just completely
disagree with me leave a comment below
I've got a few other things lined up
that I want to take a look at such as
the new horizon game but if you guys
want to see me cover something specific
then please don't forget to leave a
comment below and I'll take a look at it
thank you guys for watching I love you
all
have a great rest of your weekends good
bye
[Music]
you